a new day you're damn right but if
everybody started saying that Dawson
from there everyone's gonna think you're
going nuts
they want mass panic
the map is fabulous use that
hey youtubers it's Charlie so brand-new
trailer for Gotham Season 2 if you don't
know it's actually coming in less than
four weeks it's gonna start like the
third week in September there's just
like a couple TV shows that start around
then it's like the beginning of
superhero TV this fall I'm gonna start
with the people that we do see in this
trailer but there are a couple big
things that it leaves out that we
already know about this is called the
villains trailer or so of course that's
gonna focus on all the new big villain
characters primarily the Joker
Jerome's character the way they're
explaining it is this is like the rise
of Jerome's Joker now they're not going
so far as to say that he is the Joker
you know capital t-h-e Joker but he is a
joker the comics have always played with
the Joker's backstory just a little bit
they mess with it quite a bit during the
new 52 but originally he was the Red
Hood before he was the Joker that's why
when we got the Red Hood episode
everyone was like is this gonna be a
joke or origin story is Jerome gonna get
that Red Hood next disappointingly the
show decided not to go that route but I
feel like they've Porsche corrected a
lot of other big things in season 2 even
Ben McKenzie you know who plays Gordon
was talking a little bit about some of
the things that he thought that they got
wrong in season one it's always
fascinating to read stars criticized
their own shows but working our way down
from Jerome next big villain tigress and
her brother played by James Frain now
this is kind of funny James Frain
amazing actor huge get for any TV show
so there's gonna be that much more fun
for having in montt but have you ever
seen a TV series where he does not end
up being a villain he's been all over TV
this year like just just most recently
if he didn't see it he was part of true
detective season 2 season 1 of that is
way better so if you haven't seen true
detective season 2 yet you can totally
skip it tigress kind of looks like she's
filling that fish mooney void and that
she's like a medium badge I mean she'll
be like a big villain but she's capable
enough to marshal her own forces she'll
have like her own squad it's hard to
tell what her relationship with James
Frain is gonna be it looks like he's
going to be working more in high society
more court of owls than anything else
she's gonna be like the street-level
villain there is this really wigged out
looking scene with Barbara and her so it
looks like crazy Barbara is gonna be
team tigress this year I'm totally down
for that the trailer looks like it's
selling us on an AR
Prison Break which I feel like they shut
it on last year but better late than
never
because they've been filming episodes
for a while they have announced like a
few new minor villains that they've cast
from the comics I'll talk about them a
little bit as they come up just because
it's a little premature so far like most
of the exciting villains they show in
this trailer like the the biggest draws
of the season
the Joker tigress James Frain fish
Mooney is not coming back if you guys
didn't know Jada Pinkett Smith's only
had a one-year contract and even though
she's an amazing actress I felt like her
character just did not fit with what
this show is trying to do I felt like
she was throwing a lot of Eartha Kitt on
her performance and that's amazing if
you want to watch classic 1960s Batman
you know just very campy a lot more fun
Gotham does have like a certain fine
layer of cheese to it you know like in
the superhero sandwich that is each week
but I felt like her fish Mooney
performance was just like a little too
over the top for me also heavily
featured in the trailer the Riddler
slowly going crazier and crazier can't
wait to see more of that it was really
hard to tell you know before the finale
last year how far they were gonna take
him he got to the point of murder but
then they kind of took it back a little
bit where he hid it he covered it up and
he was acting like normal nygma again so
we might just see him get like a little
bit nuttier see some more elaborate
riddles he fills a lot of the similar
roles that Cisco does on the flash he's
like the explainer character so villains
are gonna be getting their comic book
names and got them he's probably gonna
be the one to give them but just in
general like this whole season is gonna
be permeated with the proliferation and
development of villains which I feel is
really exciting Batman's stories that
are a little bit darker usually wind up
being a lot more fun and along those
lines one of the big criticisms that a
lot of the stars of Gotham had about
season 1 themselves were that they did
like that freak of the week episodes so
season 2 they really decided to push
hard on serialization what that means is
is you'll see more running storylines
that will develop each week instead of
problems beginning and ending with each
episode I think it'll be a little easier
to develop some of their psyche
characters like Barbara for instance had
a terrible storyline in season 1 and
when you serialized you can stretch out
a small story over a number of episodes
rather than having to info-dump in like
one or two episodes the other thing you
guys should get crazy excited about is
Michael Chiklis now he's not going to be
a villain so that's
why he's not in this trailer but they've
already released a couple promo images
of him he's gonna be like the new police
captain with the rise of villains you
know yet to see new heroes come in to to
match that level he's gonna be one of
those new heroes but he'll be like a
hard-ass captain like classic 70s
ballbuster I ain't gonna take your [ __ ]
captain I'm not sure which episode he's
starting in but he'll be a series
regular so that means he's gonna be in
most episodes and unless things change
between now and the end of the season
there'll be 22 episodes total just like
last year so time to get hyped they'll
probably a couple more trailers between
now in the first episode so I'll just
I'll do videos whenever those posts be
sure to subscribe to get everything
I'll try and do as many bonus Batman
videos as possible what's gonna happen
is is once all the other shows start
like flash arrow legends of tomorrow all
that other stuff it's gonna be hard to
do bonus videos for everything so I'll
just have to prioritize so I'll try and
do as much Gotham Batman stuff before
that other stuff gets started but if
you're on the fence about season 1 I
feel like season two is gonna be light
years better it's gonna be way better
than season 1 if you guys haven't seen
it I do have a playlist for like all my
Gotham videos but it's it's unlike the
about playlist page sometimes you have
to click the more button so I'll add a
link right here if you if you haven't
watched season 1 or you need to catch up
and you can click here to catch up with
the flash season 2 it's gonna be an
amazing season of superhero TV so thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you